Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, this week was
the Agents Of SHIELD finale and I’d say
about half the questions we all had were answered,
some they’re teasing for Season 2 and then
in the last 15 minutes a whole mess of new
questions came up.
Because Season 2 was already confirmed here’s
what I’m going to do.
I’ll start with top 5 moments, then do my
review and then do some theorycrafting on
Season 2 based on what we know.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I do Marvel videos every week.
Now that SHIELD is on hiatus Tuesdays will
be Star Wars and Marvel Movie videos.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything and
leave me suggestions for bonus vids.
So careful for spoilers from the episode if
you haven’t seen it yet.
Here are my top 5 moments, Number 5 - Fitz
Sacrifices Himself For Simmons
I feel like the sacrifice means more when
it’s not a superhero.
Like when Thor jumps into a hurricane.
You’re 99 percent sure he’s going to escape
without a scratch on him.
But drowning at the bottom of the ocean and
confessing your love for someone is just so
much more meaningful.
They kept talking about life on the bottom
of the ocean I half expected some atlanteans
to swim up and save them.
But I think that was just an easter egg.
Coulson took more chances with his life, but
since he’s already been proven unkillable,
Fitz made the biggest sacrifice in the episode.
And as a result is paying the biggest price.
It sounds like his character, when he does
come back is going to be fundamentally different.
Number 4 - Nick Fury Saves The Day
He got an introduction in the episode befitting
his level of badassery.
If you’re confused about the timeline between
the end of Winter Soldier and now, it’s
basically moving in real time.
So it’s only been a couple months.
Fury formally quit SHIELD, or what’s left
of it and is pursuing the remnants of HYDRA
personally.
In the episode he really felt like he was
walking onto a holodeck, like he knew nothing
would hurt him.
I loved his call out to the one man speech.
One man can be Part, Part of Something Greater.
When he left at the end too and said I’m
everywhere, it was the writers leaving room
for him to cameo on the show again next season.
It’s funny the way Marvel never throws characters
away.
Which actually ties in to my next moment.
Number 3 - Coulson Takes Down Garrett
More like liquifies him with the Tesseract
Gun.
This was just like the moment at the end of
Avengers where the Hulk thrashes Loki around.
Garrett has this moment of evil triumph like
he thinks he’s escaped and bam, you get
that Joss Whedon head jerk to Coulson.
I just love how nonchalant he is about the
whole moment to, it just completely subverts
our expectations and that’s why it’s so
good.
It was moments like that early in the Marvel
Movie Universe that made Coulson such a fan
favorite.
Just him casually reacting to extreme situations.
Oh Asgardian Robot killing everything in the
desert, hmm.
The only bad part is that those types of things
spoil us, and because you can’t do them
every week I get bummed out it’s going to
be Guardians of The Galaxy before we get to
see something like that again.
Actually technically that’s November, SHIELD
will be back before then.
So let’s say the Season 2 premiere before
we get another “Coulson Reacts” moment.
Quick side note too.
We now know that the Tesseract gun is more
powerful than the Destroyer Gun.
Number 2 - Skye Is An Important Part of The
Evolution
We didn’t get an official answer one way
or the other, but Raina and Garrett mentioned
the words evolution and becoming something
greater in almost every scene they were in.
I’m going to save some of the theories for
the season 2 part of this video, but I love
the way the show is doing this crazy cosmic
comic book rhetoric in a way that allows them
to not have to show it to us.
I actually kept expecting Garrett to morph
into something else after Deathlok smashed
him.
Earlier when he said this is the beginning
of the end he was talking about throwing things
into the next stage of evolution.
That really made me think Terrigen Mists and
Inhumans, because something similar happened
in the Marvel Infinity comic book last year.
And Marvel is trying to develop an Inhumans
movie at some point.
And Skye’s Father at the end.
He and Raina and Skye all make me think that
there are multiple types of new aliens on
the show.
The problem is it all depends on whether an
Inhuman would be able to take a transfusion
from a Kree, a la TAHITI Blue Alien.
For the sake of argument let’s say maybe,
but Raina is probably an Inhuman.
The term Monster just fits so well, since
sometimes inhumans turn into physically monstrous
looking things when they inhale the Mists.
So in a way, SHIELD is setting up multiple
big galactic things in a really subtle way.
The show doesn’t cross over with the movies
very often.
But both influence each other.
So things that happen on SHIELD will have
an impact on the plot of movies.
Number 1 - Fury Tasks Coulson With Rebuilding
Shield
I suspected this might be the case, but I
never predicted Coulson would become director
of SHIELD.
That black box is going to be the maguffin
of Season 2, we can talk about that in a sec.
But we found out they have another new secret
base with another Patton Oswalt.
I’m going to go ahead and say Life Model
Decoy.
Wouldn’t it be funny if there was a copy
in ever single one of the super secret Nick
Fury Black Sites.
Just 50 or 60 Patton Oswalts playing video
games in the dark by themselves.
Or maybe a massive Call of Duty Lan Party.
I think my favorite quote from the episode
was Garrett saying I’m the key to the future
of the Universe.
But now it’s your turn.
Let me know what your favorite moment or moments
were.
It’s hard to pick.
But I felt a lot of Whedonverse mojo in this.
Overall the episode was a solid A. Definitely
a high point for the season.
Bill Paxton was a breath of fresh air for
the show and I’m only sorry he didn’t
come on sooner.
I think that was mostly because when they
started.
The show only had a six episode commitment.
So they didn’t even know if they’d get
renewed.
They even shot the first three episodes before
episode 1 ever aired.
So they didn’t even get feedback from the
fandom until they were mid-way through the
first half of the season.
But now that the heavy lifting task of developing
the core team members is over.
The show can start to have some more fun and
get even more meta.
I love what they did with Ward’s character.
Brett Dalton is still growing on me, his fight
with May is the perfect metaphor for how most
people reacted to him until we learned he
was Hydra.
It was like he was trolling us the whole time
with the vanilla quarterback routine.
Coulson was already a great character when
the show started.
But now that we’ve got to know him so much
better he’s so much more complex.
Before Agents of SHIELD he was essentially
the setup man for Tony Stark jokes.
Which isn’t a bad job, but Nick Fury named
him as a core Avenger in this episode.
So Marvel and Disney just made Coulson as
important as Captain America and Iron Man.
I don’t think that means we’ll ever see
a Coulson movie, but I’m totally fine with
that.
A lot of the credit this season goes to Jed
Whedon and Maurissa Tancheron.
They really did most of the work this season.
A lot of people realize that even though Joss
Whedon was involved in getting this show off
the ground.
They were the ones that ran the show all season
while he was away working on Avengers 2.
So if you really like the show.
They’re the ones to thank.
When it was announced SHIELD got renewed for
Season 2 they even posted themselves dancing
crazy on instagram, so high fives to them.
Now it’s time for some Theorycrafting on
Season 2.
So everybody start scanning dialogue and easter
eggs again.
First off, the plot.
That little black box Fury gave Coulson will
be where most of their ideas for missions
come from.
They used it to find their new base.
So they’re going to just keep “finding”
interesting things in that database to investigate.
Just because Patton Oswalt was in the base
when they arrived doesn’t mean he’ll be
in every episode, but he’ll definitely cameo
again.
They’re probably going to spend most of
their time on the plane traveling places.
As for the rest of the team, Triplett is probably
going to replace Ward as the muscle man for
a little while.
But Brett Dalton isn’t off the show.
Ward will still be a main cast member.
Coulson said they’d use him to get HYDRA
intel.
So either they’re going to permanently house
him inside that special room on the plane,
or they’ll keep him locked up at that base.
My money is on them keeping him close by.
So Ming Na can slap him around once a week.
Fitz is the big question mark right now.
They made it sound like he’d lost some brain
function.
So maybe part of his arc next season will
be learning how to be a team member when he’s
not super smart anymore.
Like learning to contribute and be special
in a new way.
He’s not off the show either, so he’s
definitely still on the team.
Garrett is definitely a puddle of goo, so
he won’t be the villain again.
That honor will probably fall to Skye’s
mystery Father.
The Inhuman.
He’s definitely not a Kree.
That’s funny too, because the macguffin
this season was the super blood and on Arrow
it was the mirakuru.
And next season it looks like SHIELD’s villain
will be Skye’s Father and on Arrow it looks
like Thea’s father or Felicity’s father
might be the villain.
I know they’re not copying each other, but
the similarities in story elements is just
too weird to not think about.
Moving on to Skye’s heritage.
Like I just said, Raina, who I suspect is
an Inhuman who hasn’t taken in the Mists
of Terrigen, has a pre-existing relationhip
with Skye’s father.
Who did not look like that Blue Kree alien.
Ergo, my best theory right now is that she
is an Inhuman.
But she’s not like a princess or anything.
Black Bolt is still king of the Inhumans and
that guy did not look like Black Bolt.
He seemed pretty evil.
And in case you couldn’t see, he was covered
in blood for unknown reasons.
I expect this Inhumans secret to be like the
Coulson TAHITI mystery next season.
It’s going to take most of the season for
the show to fully explain it.
Let me know what your big theories for season
2 are and if you agree that Skye is an Inhuman
based on all the evidence.
So next week I’ll be doing Marvel Movie
videos and Star Wars on tuesday.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything and
leave me suggestions for bonus videos.
Tomorrow is the Arrow Finale and the first
Flash trailer.
If you check the description I posted a link
to my master video schedule so you can find
out when I’m posting stuff.
Right now click here to learn all about the
Agent Carter TV Show and the Netflix Shows
and Click here for a breakdown of Ben Affleck’s
Batsuit and the new Batmobile.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow!